[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEONIDAS KONTOTHANASSIS:
Welcome, everybody.
My name is Leonidas
Kontothanassis.
I'm an engineering
director, at Google,
in charge of Cloud networking--
multiple products
fall in my team.
The one that I'm going
to talk about today
is our Cloud CDN
offering, and I hope
you're all well caffeinated.
This is probably a
more technical talk
than might have seemed
otherwise-- so lots
of technical details.
So get ready.
OK, so how is this talk
going to be organized?
I'm going to talk a little
bit about our Cloud network.
This is not about the CDN.
This is the network itself.
The reason I'm going to
spend a little bit of time
covering is it has affected
many of the decisions
we've made on how we build it--
how we built the CDN
offering on top of it,
and now I want to make
another part clear.
And then I'm going to move onto
the content delivery aspects.
I'm going to spend some time
talking about the architecture
of our CDN--
you know, the platforms
that we used to build it,
and the logistics management--
how we make sure that
machines stay up,
performing well,
getting upgraded,
replaced, et cetera, et cetera.
I'm going to spend some
time on our mapping system
that is the heart of the CDN.
This is the system
that decides how
users get routed to
the right machines,
and how traffic
from those machines
get routed back to users.
Those two decisions
are independent.
I'm going to spend a little bit
of time on the product itself,
like the features that
we support and some
of the features that
we're hoping to support
in the not-too-distant future--
talk about performance
and how we measure
performance internally
and also externally,
and finally close with
a small demo showing
the benefits of having
CDN delivery for a, say,
graphics-heavy site.
So this is a depiction
of the Google Network.
Google Network changes, of
course you know, all the time.
Currently, we have 20
regions with compute cycles
available in them, so those are
places where you can go and get
storage computation like the
whole heavy cloud machinery.
We have 125 PoPs.
Those are locations where
we run our Edge systems,
and where we do caching.
These are places where you can
meet our network for private
interconnect, for instance,
if you're trying to connect
your on-prem facility to us,
but we will use them heavily
for our CDN offering--
and 13 sub cables connecting
all those facilities
to one another.
It's one of the unique
features, of Google,
in that we run a global private
network unlike other cloud
providers, which typically
run isolated instances of data
centers in many locations.
We run one global network
that connects them all.
This has multiple advantages.
It gives you
private connectivity
between machines that
are running, say,
in Asia to those that are
running in Europe or the United
States.
And we use it heavily, as
well, to do various tricks
around traffic
routing, GRE, MPLS,
to be able to store traffic
that may have entered
our network in one location
to another location within it.
That that is preferable
for serving purposes.
This is another
view of our network.
This is actually showing the
serving locations that we have.
There is 90 of those--
90 different cities
around the world, which
sit on the edge of the network.
Those are the ones that we
use both for Google and Cloud
CDN serving.
They are very large deployments,
typically multiple petabytes
of cache ability, but we
have a much larger footprint
that sits off net inside ISPs.
So there's about 4,000
of those deployments.
They tend to be a lot
smaller in terms of size.
Today, Google traffic is
roughly half and half.
About half the
traffic that Google
has for its internal properties
comes from the on-net nodes--
about half comes from
the off-net nodes.
Performance differences
between those two deployments
is actually highly
variable by country.
For instance, in the US, we
find that be on-net nodes
do far better than the off-net.
Some places like Africa or Latin
America, the inverse is true.
Some places like
Europe, the difference
then tends to be
practically negligible.
We don't see much
of a difference.
The reason that
we have both is we
want to have as good a
relationship with ISPs
as we can.
In many of those
cases, ISPs see benefit
in having caches
in their network.
In other cases, they don't.
We play along with
whatever suits them best,
so we picked the best
interconnect capability
that fits our ISP partners.
We are working to make
the off-net caches
available to Google Cloud.
I'll say a little bit
more about that later,
but right now only
the on-net ones
are available for
the Cloud offering.
OK, our Cloud CDN--
so we account for--
our Google and Cloud
CDN, we account for a lot
of the internet traffic.
According to Sandvine, Google
is responsible for about 25%
of all internet bits.
85% of that comes from
YouTube, but the other parts
are actually significant.
And Cloud is the fastest
growing part of that traffic.
It's growing faster
than YouTube.
It is growing faster
than the other sources
of traffic for Google.
We are seeing more than
50% year-over-year growth--
demand from over 130 countries.
We have had to deal with
an enormous catalog size,
so this informed
the decisions on how
we built those Edge caches.
The primary reason for that is
that the most common content
that we're serving is video.
Video tends to be very large.
And user-generated video, which
is what we get out of YouTube,
really is probably
the largest catalog.
It's multiple hexabytes of data.
So as I said before,
Cloud traffic
is the one that is
rising the most rapidly,
and that's the
one where we think
that we have to invest
the most heavily
to help our Cloud customers
get the benefits of our CDN.
And the infrastructure,
as I said,
is shared between Google
and Cloud traffic.
So we've built our CDN with
the following principles.
Number one is ease of use,
so the key innovation here
is that we have a single IP
for serving content worldwide.
There's a lot of technology
that goes behind that.
I will spend some
time describing
how that technology works.
Why would a customer care?
There is, oftentimes
especially for media partners,
we found that they want to
work with ISPs to either
flat rate, or low rate,
or have a deal that
allows their content
to be charged
as part of an ISP contract
like a cellular contract.
Typically, ISPs know how to do
that only through IP addresses.
They want to say, OK,
tell me what IP addresses
your client is
going to come from,
and being able to give them one
makes you their best friend.
So it's very easy for
them to configure one IP.
This is the content
where it's coming from.
I know exactly how
to deal with that.
The more you give them, the more
difficult their life becomes.
We made it very easy to
activate our Cloud CDN.
If you are already
on Google Cloud--
yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Is this a P4?
IPv6 or IPv4?
LEONIDAS KONTOTHANASSIS:
The question is, can this
be an IPv6 or IPv4?
The answer is both.
You can choose.
So we have a
single-click activation
on top of our global
load balancer.
So if you've got your backend
sitting inside of Google Cloud,
and you decide that you
want cache delivery,
it's a trivial turn on.
Just one click, I
will actually show you
the configuration page.
We care a lot about security,
so by default all delivery
is done over SSL with
no additional cost.
We have also other programs
for configuring certs,
and uploading them,
and managing them.
Your backends, the ones that
live inside the Google Cloud,
are unexposed to the internet.
So if you bring up your VMs,
or you have a backend storage
packet, by default
that one does not
have to be exposed to
the internet traffic.
The CDN takes all
of the connection
and then connects through
Google's private network
to those backends, and it's got
a built-in SYN-flood defense.
So because the backends are
not exposed to the internet,
any attack will stop
at the proxy layer.
We have seen the largest
attacks seen in the history
of the internet--
we believe and--
you know, size helps.
When your carry about 25%
of all internet traffic,
it's kind of hard
for you to come down.
And finally, you
know performance
has been another guiding force.
Obviously, we care
about that internally.
We think that latency is
critical to the success of web
delivery.
We invest heavily on
state-of-the-art protocols,
so our CDN supports HTTP/2.
That was something
that we built and now
is part of industry standards.
It supports QUIC, which is
not yet an industry standard
but is going through the IETF.
And of course it's supported
by Chrome and Mozilla.
And we have open libraries if
you want to build your own app,
and we have
measurements that show
that we have industry-leading
performance in both latency,
availability, and throughput.
So more of that coming later.
OK, so what does
our CDN look like?
So at a particular
metro, we have a layer
of packet forwarders,
where traffic
is coming into our network.
The name for those packet
forwarders is Maglev.
There is a very good
SIGCOMM paper from 2016
that describes the behavior.
Maglevs can do multiple
millions of packets per second.
They don't have to do a lot.
What they have to
do is figure out
where the right destination
for a particular packet is
and send it there.
Typically, it's right next
to them but not always.
I'll get more to that later.
Then we have our L1 proxy.
That is, essentially,
the caching proxy
that sits at the
edge of the network.
There is three layers of cache
sitting right next to that L1
proxy.
There is an in-memory cache for
the hottest possible, you know,
part of the content.
That tends to be on the order of
single digits of terabytes only
used for something
that is extremely
hot that needs to be served, you
know, at very, very high rate.
There is what we
call medium cache.
That is on the order of
triple digits of terabytes--
depends on the location.
Demand isn't always the same for
all locations on the internet.
It's based on Flash.
We use it very heavily for small
contents that are very latency
sensitive but also some
big content that, you know,
ends up being hot enough to
merit promotion to this cache.
And then there is finally what
we call large cache, which
is based on spinning disk.
That is typically on
the double-digit orders
of petabytes.
It was built with
YouTube in mind.
We need a cache that gives us
98%, 99% hit rate on YouTube,
so it had to be fairly
large to accommodate that.
This hierarchy of
caches is what's
being made available
to our Cloud customers.
The L1 proxies will
obviously look things up
in their local cache hierarchy
to see if it's available.
If not, then they
will actually go back
to the instances that
have the original content.
Depending on the
kind of instance,
there may be another
layer of caching.
It is what we call
a shield cache.
Not all origins require that.
For instance, if your
origin happens to be
Google Cloud Storage.
Google Cloud Storage is a
fairly big system in itself.
It does not need protection,
so there the L1 proxies
will go to it directly.
But if you're running your
single VM, for instance,
there will be a layer of caches
that would aggregate requests
coming from the first layer,
so that you don't get hammered.
How do we build this?
These are actually pictures
of racks out in the field.
So the way we
build it is we have
a very modular
horizontal architecture,
so what we do if we want to
augment a particular location,
we just add another rack,
which both increases storage--
since, you know, racks
are integrated storage
and egress bit pumps
and it increases
in our egress capability.
We tend to upgrade our machines
when they hit utilization
of about 70%, and we have a
fairly sophisticated logistics
program to make sure that
just-in-time augmentations
happen correctly.
And the limiting factor here
is the breadth of network
here, so those machines
plug routers or switches
at the edge of the network.
So the breadth of that gear is
one of the limiting factors,
and it is one of the things
that forced us to do work.
So up until a few years ago,
we were using regular routers
as sold by people like Cisco,
Juniper, possibly others.
But what we were observing was
that the port density on those
was increasing slower than
the traffic was increasing,
and we were limited both
by cost and scalability
if we were to continue
to use that technology.
So we kind of looked
at them and said, you
know, what does a router do?
Well, you know it does BGP.
It exchanges information,
routing information
with the rest of the internet.
It does packet forwarding.
When it gets a packet,
it knows how to send it
to the right final destination.
It does ACLs, so
packets, that are not
supposed to go out
to the internet
or are not supposed to come into
our network from the internet,
get dropped at that point.
And it does this in a not very
effective packaging from a cost
perspective, so we wanted
to take all those things
and put them together into
something that would be
both more scalable and cheaper.
So the solution to that is the
system that we call Espresso.
A full paper on
Espresso has been
published in this
year's SIGCOMM,
for anybody that was interested.
Espresso comes with three parts.
The first is a peering fabric.
The peering fabric is
effectively a switch.
It has no routing smarts in it.
It just knows how to connect
sort of our side of the network
to the rest of the internet.
It's much cheaper,
because it doesn't
have all these extra
capabilities that routers do,
and it is much more dense.
You can get about 10x the
number of ports on a switch
than you can get on a router.
So now that you
have this switch,
you need some way to
ship traffic through it,
so what we have is we have moved
all of the stuff in software.
So we ran on our
own BGP listener
on the servers that
are sitting on the Edge
to get the routes
from the other side,
and we pass that information
to our mapping system.
And I will explain
how that works.
We run two layers
of controllers--
a global controller that
determines where traffic is
supposed to go, and that global
controller produces assignments
about once a minute, which
it ships to the servers,
and it tells them--
for this particular
destination, I
need you to send it out to
that switch on that port.
And we have mechanisms
implemented,
using GRE and PLS, that allow
us to do that with the switches
that we have.
And we have a local
controller that essentially
reacts on the order of seconds.
Routes on the
internet come and go.
Somebody may withdraw a route.
He might say, you
know, I can't be
reached at this point from
this particular location.
The local controller
is the one that's
supposed to take that
information and say, OK,
where else can I send it until
the global controller can
compute a more
optimized assignment
for that destination?
And all of the packet processing
that the routers were doing
has moved to the CPUs.
Earlier, I showed you
a picture of something
that we called Maglev that
was doing packet processing
on the incoming side.
Maglev has been
extended, and now it
has a different internal name.
It can do packet
processing on both
the incoming and
the outgoing side,
so we can send the packets
to the right destination.
So logistics, the difficulty
here comes from the fact
that we're running a very
large fleet in many places.
We have about 5% of our machines
in some kind of repair need
at any point in time, and this
requires active management
for a fleet that has tens
of thousands of servers.
If you were to do
that manually, that
would be a very high burden
to our operations side,
so we have taken
extensive efforts
to automate all of this
work, including upgrades,
installations, and repairs.
All of that work happens
through a portal, where
we meet with our ISP partners.
And we, through
that portal, have
workflows that allows us to do
dozens of turnups every week--
dozens of repairs every week.
And in more than 90%
of those, no Googler
actually has to touch anything.
It's all automated.
So a machine gets shipped.
It gets connected either
by a contract worker
or by the ISP themselves.
And then from that point
on, the system automatically
takes over, it logs
into the machine,
installs the right software,
brings up the BGP session,
assigns it, brings it
into the mapping system,
and traffic starts flowing.
And it knows how to do that
actually in a smart way,
so that traffic gets
brought up gradually,
so that we don't overwhelm
the backbone network-- filling
a very large cache with
a very large workload.
So peering, this is
one of the key benefits
of working with Google.
We have invested very
heavily with our ISP partners
to make sure that we have the
best possible reachability.
A lot of the time,
people think of a CDN,
and they think it is an
issue of machine capacity.
Yes, machine capacity
matters, but what we find
is that machine capacity
is something that
typically is controlled by us.
We get to ship the machines.
We get to install them.
It's an easier
problem to solve then
something that requires an
interlocutor on the other side.
Bringing up additional
peering with a partner
means that both you and them
have to be in agreement,
and you have to coordinate.
So for peering, we actively
manage and forecast
our peering demand,
so we actually
look at what we think we're
going to need with our partners
not just over the
next three months,
but over the next three years.
And we communicate all of
that information to them
through the portal,
and we tell them
that this is the
location to where we see
the traffic is coming to you.
We think we need augment.
We think we're going to meet
the augment this many months
from now.
We aim to have a
one-hop distance
to 98% of all ISPs
on the internet,
and those tend to be
the most major ones.
And we aim to have
multiple paths
into each one of those ISPs.
So we are not content
in having just one place
where we can connect with them.
We want to connect to them in
as many places as possible.
For the big ones, that's
actually fairly easy.
They understand the
value of doing that.
They see it for
their own benefit,
because if you can
connect in multiple places
then you can give them
content close to their users,
so they don't have to use
their own backbone to move
that content around.
For the smaller
ones, sometimes we
have to find alternate paths
through transit providers
since they might not
be able to meet us
in more than one location.
And we use our mapping
system to actively manage
those connections and steer the
traffic to the right connection
at any point in time.
The mapping system--
OK, so what is the
mapping problem here?
So the mapping
problem is that we
have multiple paths to every
user just because of the way
we're building the system.
We have billions of users
that we need to accommodate.
Thankfully, those
billions of users
can usually be
subdivided to groups,
so you don't have to deal with
each one of them individually,
although we try to.
I'll say more about that later,
but still millions of user
groups.
And demand, capacity,
and congestion changes
in real time, so
you need a system
that can deal with
all those constraints.
So what do we have to do?
We, essentially, have to
generate an assignment of users
to sites and links.
Remember here, it's not
enough to just send something
to a particular location.
You also have to
know exactly which
links since we are peering
with multiple ISPs in that one
location--
are going to get used
for this particular user.
You have to respect
the available capacity
of the machines and the
network, so the supply
is often greater than--
it has to be greater
than the demand, which
is not always true.
You have to respect
the peer preferences.
Our peers, our ISP
partners, give us policy
that they want us to enforce.
They say that I want, you know,
this particular set of users
to be served from here, or this
other particular set of users
to be served from
some other place.
We want to minimize cost, and
we want to maximize quality,
pursuant to those constraints.
So what does the mapping
system look like?
There's a number of inputs.
Obviously, we get BGP and
all the other routing data.
This essentially tells
us where the users are--
how far away they are from any
one point in network distance.
Network distance
is number of hops,
not necessarily what the
latency is between, sort of,
that location where
the user is, or what
the throughput is between
that location and the user.
We augment that with our
own observations of latency.
As we serve users, we
collect information.
We constantly run a
small trickle of users
to other locations--
what we call
spraying-- so that
we can see how
the ideal location, according to
BGP, compares with other ones.
The network topology, we
have built our own model
for both sort of our network and
what the internet looks like.
We actually have a fairly
sophisticated model
for all major ISPs.
We share it with
them, and we tell them
where we see bottlenecks,
not only sort of--
I mean, not on our side.
That we keep
internally and we fix.
But we also tell them when we
see bottlenecks on their side,
and we work with them to fix it.
One of the things that was
published a few years back
was the user score.
This is like a
YouTube number that
tells users and ISPs what
their score is in terms of sort
of for video consumption.
We actually spent a
good couple of quarters
working with the ISPs, before we
made it available to end users,
to make sure that they
had every opportunity
to fix their
networks and improve
the quality and
the score that they
would get on this before we
made it available to the world.
And obviously load reports--
you know we want to
know how much traffic
is going in any one place.
So then the system starts
with a link and machine limit
computation.
It determines what are the
capacities and the demand
in, sort of, every
one of those elements.
It does a preliminary candidate
selection, so it says,
OK, for this particular
user, it looks
like not the whole
world as a good choice
for where to assign them to.
But here is the top three,
or four, or five choices.
And then that is
fed to an optimizer.
The first, sort of, parts of
the system are eager algorithms,
which--
greedy algorithms,
which simply do best
guesses for what those are.
The optimizer is a far more
complicated piece of code.
It has linear programming
to try and find
sort of the optimal solutions.
And we're trying to minimize
the size of the input data,
so that it can run within
a one-minute interval.
We hope to produce
those assignments
about once a minute,
so that we can
shift traffic around
in response to changing
demand from the internet.
For safety reasons, we
archive every single one
of the outputs of all
of those subsystems.
If, at any point in time,
something goes wrong,
we want to be able to restore
the system to a sane state,
and say, OK, we're not
quite sure what is going on,
but here is an assignment that
worked fine 15 minutes ago.
Please use that
and move forward.
And finally, we
actually push that
to a system that does a
resolution of the user request
and gives them the location
that they should be going--
that they should be going to.
So this is one area
where we have deviated
from what many other CDNs do.
Instead of relying on
an indirection, which
is quite common of
users to resolvers,
and then sort of figuring
out, from the resolver, what
the user should be
assigned, we rely
on either direct integration
with the player for the YouTube
or on our AnyCast solution to
know exactly who the client is
and send them to
the right location.
So in the previous
picture, where
I was showing the
Maglevs, what that
would look like is a request
that arrives from a user
knows exactly the
client IP for that user.
We don't need to
know the resolver.
The resolver is irrelevant.
Everything goes, always,
to the same IP anyway.
So when the request packet
comes into our network,
it comes with a client IP,
and the forwarders look at it
and determine is the local
machine the optimal machine
to serve this piece of content?
If the answer is
yes, then it's simply
a hand off sort of
on the local machine,
but some fraction of the
time that is not the case.
The mapping system
has determined
that another cache
is better suited
for serving this content.
It will then take that
packet and forward it
to that other cache, and
responses then come out direct.
So the response is
asymmetric to the request,
so the response will
go out from a port that
is closest to this user, as
far as the mapping system was
able to determine.
So I already spoke the first
few bullets on this slide.
There is some
additional enhancements
that we put into the mapping
system to make it perform
as well as possible.
One is the dynamic
estimation of path limits--
what we call end-to-end limits.
What that feature does
is it tries to determine,
for any group of users, what
is the capacity of the internet
between sort of a cache and
where the end user lies.
The way it does that
actually is-- we
have observed that the internet
has a one level of performance
when it is lightly
loaded, which is
very easy to determine because
it happens at trough times.
In the middle of the night,
there's not too many people
trying to use those connections.
So it's never zero.
There's always
someone, and I think
the ratio between trough
and peak is sort of two
to one or so.
So there's still a lot of
demand at all times of the day
and night, but because
it's so much lower,
you can sort of assume that
the network is unburdened.
And the performance that you are
observing at that point in time
is indicative of the system
that is operating at its best
capability.
So then, what we
do is we constantly
observe the throughput
and the latency
that we're seeing at
peak times, and if we're
starting to see
that it is deviating
from that optimal observation
that we have seen at trough
times, then we kick in,
sort of, the algorithm
that spreads that
load to other paths.
And we measure those
other paths as well,
so that we get an equalized
level of performance
across all the paths.
There's no point-- yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So night in one
place is day in another, right?
Night in one place
of the world is day
in another place of the world.
So how do you suppress noise?
LEONIDAS KONTOTHANASSIS: Yes, so
night in one part of the world
is day in another
part of the world,
so how do you suppress noise?
The reality is that
assignments are localized,
so an Indian user will be
sent to an Indian location,
and a US user will be
sent to a US location.
So night and day, they
are very different.
And the measurement is actually
relative to the users that
are supposed to that
local location, as opposed
to somebody who is coming from
the other side of the world.
And another big
thing that we do is
we try to tell the users apart.
Not every user has
the same capability.
The announcements that
we get from the internet
are coming in these large
blocks that we call CIDR blocks,
so oftentimes an ISP will say,
hey, here is half a million
or, you know, a couple
of million users.
Please route them sort
of this way for me,
and the reality is those are not
always the same set of users.
They don't have the
same capabilities,
so we constantly
observe, for each user,
what the capability is.
And we try to divide
them in smaller groups,
so that we can assign them
independently rather than
treating them as one big lump
based on how the ISP advertises
them to us.
So what we've seen-- as we've
been working on the mapping
system and improving it--
we have reduced the
amount of backbone usage,
like the traffic that has to
go from a particular cache
to another exit point from
about 10% originally down
to zero now.
We managed to
reduce our miss rate
by properly assigning
requests to the right rack--
from about 4% to 2%.
And we had one other
feature in our system, which
is if the mapping
system kind of screws
up, the caches are allowed
to defend themselves
by redirecting
some traffic away.
So this is only used
for YouTube, which
has a very, very large demand.
We don't use the
redirect feature
for Cloud CDN and
our cloud customers
obviously, because we
don't control their client,
and a redirect may end up
being harmful for them.
But because YouTube is such
a large part of the CDN,
being able to redirect
that traffic away
leaves room for everybody else.
And modeling the machines
and the disk capacities,
we're able to reduce the
redirect rate from 3% to 1%.
And this mapping system
actually matters.
On the ingress side, we
find that if you just
rely on BGP, which is the
closest hop, about 14%, 15%,
of the traffic would land in a
place that would not give you
optimal performance,
so being able to take
these incoming requests and
forward them to the right cache
actually makes a difference
not for most of the traffic,
but a good enough chunk
of the traffic to matter.
So here is actually some
small performance results
of turning on the aggregation
and end-to-end limits.
It's experiments showing
rebuffer rates and retransmit
rates.
You can see market
increases and decreases
in retransmit rates and
reductions in rebuffer rate
when we turned those things on.
So now that I've actually
covered a little bit
on the technical, I
want to go a bit more
on the product philosophy--
what is it that we're trying
to achieve with our Cloud CDN?
So first of all, I want to
say that we are partners--
we're a cloud company first and
foremost, not a CDN company,
so yes, we build our
own CDN because we
want to offer our
customers a one-stop shop.
If they want to buy
something from us
and have it all work
seamlessly and easy,
then they should
be able to do that.
At the same time,
we fully understand
that many of our customers,
that are coming to our Cloud,
already have existing
relationships,
or they want features that
we are not offering yet.
So we have a large
number of partners,
and we expect that
we will continue,
for the indefinite
future, to have
a large number of CDN partners.
And our customers are
free to choose sort of us,
them, a combination.
Many of them want
to be multi-vendor.
That should continue to be the
case for the indefinite future.
However, we want to make
ours as easy to use,
and we hope that
customers will see
the value of sticking with
a one-stop shop and pick us.
Obviously, this decision
rests with the customers,
but we are making it as
easy to use as possible.
Here is, actually,
the configuration.
After you have a
backend, you can
see that the Enable CDN button
is just a single check box.
So once you have configured
a backend inside Google,
you want to enable caching.
The configuration is about
as trivial as it gets.
Any other integration
will surely
be more complicated than
that, I guarantee it.
We offer easy
management-- log delivery
inside the Cloud and
performance statistics
all in the same Pantheon
view, where you will actually
go and configure your CDN
and your other backends.
So again, if you are used
to having a partnership
with Google, you are actually
using our other products,
you're familiar with our tools--
the same set of
familiar tools will
be used to visualize and
control your CDN and the things
that it generates.
We've been adding
features to it,
so that we are sort of
late starters in this game.
We initially focused very
heavily on infrastructure,
because we were building
something for internal use.
And now that we are
externalizing the CDN,
we are finding that our
customers want more things
than what Google needed
internally, so we've added
support for custom cache keys.
So if you decide
that you don't want
your whole URL to be a key, then
you can select pieces of it.
We've added support
for signed URLs.
This is something that
many of our customers
have asked for more
secure delivery.
We are partnering with
another Cloud product,
that we have called Anvato to
support live streaming if this
is something that
you want to do,
or you can just do live
streaming in your own way.
But if you want a
package solution,
then we have a full
integration with Anvato.
Obviously, we seek support that
wasn't specific to the CDN,
but once we did it for all
Cloud, CDN got it for free.
User-defined header insertion,
many of our customers
have asked for
that, so we support
certain sets of
headers that can be
inserted into their requests.
You can support multiple
certs and managed certs
as part of our CDN offering.
TLS cipher selection-- very
important for compliance.
Some customers only want to
use particular SSL ciphers.
We give them the option of
selecting which ones they want.
Content takedown, that's
obviously a feature
that every CDN needs to have.
Customers sometimes
make mistakes.
They put up content that
they don't want to put up.
If it's out in the
caches, you need
to be able to get rid of it.
And finally, one of the
more recent things--
which is going GA
next week, it has
been announced for awhile now.
It's in open beta--
is what we call large
object media support.
Our origins are in video,
and it was one of the things
that-- our Cloud CDN
customers were complaining--
was even though we had great
infrastructure for video,
our initial implementation
for Cloud CDN
had a limitation on object
size that has been taken away.
There's been a few things
that had to happen.
Because video content
tends to be fairly large,
we don't want to fetch it all in
one fell swoop into the cache,
so we chunk it into
smaller pieces.
And we fetch the piece
that is necessary,
based on what is being
requested from the user side.
There is one contract
that we need to have
between us and the customer.
The customer has
to guarantee to us
that they have an origin
that supports range requests
and will actually tell us
what the size of the object
is when we first
do a range request.
As we've been
deploying it, I think
we found about 0.01%
of our customers
doesn't actually have
compliant origins.
This is surprising that
they don't, but we've
disabled the feature for
those customers who are
working with them to fix it.
And this is the thing that
has delayed us slightly
in declaring GA.
We want to make sure
that nobody gets
harmed in the process
of rolling this out.
So a Next talk wouldn't be
interesting without announcing
some things that should
come down the pike.
So the number one
thing that we've seen
is our customers are saying that
it's great that you have a CDN.
It's great that it works
so well with Google Cloud,
but you know what?
We have assets that live
outside of Google Cloud.
And most of them are talking
about their on-prem assets,
and they're saying we
need support for that.
And some of them are saying, OK,
and we also want multi-cloud.
We want to be able to
run some stuff on you
and some stuff on
your competitors,
and maybe we would like to use
your CDN regardless of where
our origins are sitting.
So we are working in
bringing that to Cloud CDN.
I'm hoping that by some time--
the end of this year-- we'll
have something to announce.
The other big thing that I
announced, sort of earlier,
is we're working in
extending our Cloud
CDN to the off-net
fleet that we have.
The difficulty
there is primarily
how do you do AnyCast off net?
You know, you don't
control the network
like you do when you're
inside the Google environment.
I think we have a solution.
We are working with
our ISP partners
to allow us to do
this AnyCast solution.
They are very incentivized
to work with us.
They want to have the traffic
that Cloud CDN generates--
come from the off-net caches.
They would rather
not have it come
through peering for those
that have off-net caches,
so we think we have the good
working relationship that
will allow this to happen.
Integration with
Cloud Armor, this
is a completely
separate product,
but it is part of
the security suite.
People want to be able to set
both sort of blocking rules
for particular
IPs, or countries--
or protection for SQL
injection, or cross
scripting, or other things.
So we have support for that.
It is now supported
sort of at the LB layer.
We are working on extending
it to the caching layer.
The product has
already been announced.
It is in, I think,
alpha or beta.
Forgive me for not
remembering exactly.
One other optimization
that we're
trying to add for customers,
especially those that
want to do live events with
very, very low latency,
is the assume public content
for optimizing miss rate.
Right now, what the CDN does
is when it gets a request,
it doesn't know
whether the response
is going to be cachable or not.
It cannot know until the
origin has responded,
because the information is
available in the headers.
So because it has
to be conservative,
and it doesn't want
to introduce latency,
when it gets, say, three
requests for the same thing
it has to forward
them all to the origin
at the same time in
order to make sure
that they don't get delayed.
Under this mode, a
customer would guarantee
that the content
is always cachable,
so then you can forward
just the first request
and leave all of the
other ones sort of waiting
for the first answer to come.
And then you can get that
answer back to all the users
that have been waiting.
And finally, we're
working with Anvato
to build an end-to-end
low-latency live video support
system.
We have internal
demonstrations, which
shows that we can go from
encoder to final serving
in low single-digit seconds.
We're hoping to make that
available to our Cloud
customers as well.
Performance-- we have a very
extensive set of evaluations
for how well we're doing.
The, probably,
most important one
is the one that we share
with our ISP partners,
because that helps us not
only sort of improve our site,
but it helps them improve
their site as well.
So this is an example of
an ISP partner, ASN 7018.
And for those of you who
are in this business,
you should know who
that partner is.
And what we do is we capture a
small fraction of all packets.
As we know, we send them
down, and we analyze sort
of those packets, both
from the outgoing side
and on the incoming side,
to detect bottlenecks.
So we also insert some
packets, duplicate packets
with reduced TTLs, so we can
see sort of where they reach
the network on the other
side, and how long it
takes for the ICMP
expire to come back.
And all that goes into sort
of an analysis system that
determines where the bottlenecks
in the communication are.
So this is an example.
The system auto adjusts,
and essentially takes
the worst possible
path, and assigns
that to be the reddest
part of the spectrum.
In this particular case, the
reddest part of the spectrum
is still 8 megabits per second,
as you can see from the slider
above.
So this is a very
well-provisioned ISP,
not one that has bottlenecks.
Every user is getting still at
least 8 megabits per second,
which is more than good
enough for even ultra HD,
but we have that
for ISP partner.
We have thousands of them,
and we share that information
with them constantly.
And we help build better
connectivity for us
and also for them.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
publicly published paper
or a dataset [INAUDIBLE]?
LEONIDAS KONTOTHANASSIS:
No, this is not
a publicly available dataset.
It is available to ISP partners.
If any of you are
an ISP or a telco,
then you can sign
up to the portal
and get your own information.
Unfortunately, for
various reasons,
we cannot tell one ISP
information about what other
ISPs are doing.
Internal evaluations are great.
The reality is
that we trust them
more than we trust
anything externally,
but we fully understand that the
people that want to use our CDN
don't necessarily have to take
our word on how well we're
performing.
So we've commissioned a study
from an external partner,
Cedexis in this case.
Cedexis has this fairly
interesting system
where they have clients
around the world living
inside people's
browsers or apps,
and what they do is
they've convinced
a whole bunch of
websites to allow
them to install a
bit of JavaScript
sort of on their website.
And after the website
has finished loading,
that JavaScript, which
belongs to Cedexis,
can kick off
measurements against any
of a number of destinations and
see how well those destinations
are performing.
So it's a very interesting
measurement system.
It's got millions of vantage
points or tens of millions
of vantage points
around the world.
And it's very
difficult to optimize
for because the requests
are coming from everywhere,
so it's essentially a
depiction of the internet.
Cedexis is actually
publishing those reports.
There is a much fuller
list of all the CDNs.
This is a Cloud
conference, so I'm actually
presenting the results for our
biggest cloud competitor, AWS
and CloudFront.
But all the results for all
CDNs, including our own,
can be found in that URL.
I encourage you to go
and click on the link
and look at them for yourself.
We have results for latency.
We have results for throughput.
The early part of the
graph, that was actually
a problem like a small
downtime in the Cedexis side,
so for a couple of days
the data was missing.
But then the graph
comes back up.
And availability-- one
interesting thing to note
here is you can
tell that this is
a real internet-based
measurement.
Availability is
actually pretty bad.
It's about 99%.
If you look at sort
of the guarantees
that you get from almost every
CDN, it's like multiple nine,
including ourselves.
We promised four nines,
but we promised four nines
on the availability
of the caches.
The internet is a
very nasty place,
and this includes people that
are sitting behind broken Wi-Fi
at their homes, or
they turn the microwave
on when the measurement
happens to be going on.
So the failures that
you're seeing here
is sort of the real
effects of what happens
sort of out there in the world.
You still need the four nines
in the cache to get that.
If you didn't have those four
nines in the cache level,
you'd be getting
something worse than that,
and that's where you see some
separation between the CDNs.
The biggest contributor
to what you're seeing
is what happens outside on
the internet, but the CDNs
themselves actually contribute
to a certain extent as well.
I have a small demo on
the benefits of CDN.
So we've configured a backend.
For the purposes of this demo,
we put this backend in India,
so it's really far
away from here.
And we have the origin.
Just for this demo we made the
origin publicly accessible,
so we can go to it directly.
It is not blanketed
from the internet.
And here, I've run
some trace routes.
I actually ran them
right before I came in.
You can see that the origin's
about 307 milliseconds away
from here, and the CDN IP
that is caching the content
is about 4 milliseconds
away from here,
which is pretty good.
So here's side by side.
On the left side, you
have the CDN site.
It is loading, and you
can see how fast it is.
On the right side,
you have something
coming from the origin.
You can see how
much slower it is.
Chrome has this very beautiful
feature called Developer Tools,
and if you click
on the Network tab
you can actually see how long
it takes for this page to show.
So on the CDN side, it
takes about 300 milliseconds
to load a page that has
about 15 fairly large images.
This is a CDN configuration
that includes QUIC,
so it's our best protocol for
loading persistent connections.
The right-hand side is
sort of an origin that
is going over HTTP/11, so it's
not really a fair comparison
but is a one that I created
to showcase the difference.
I encourage you.
The slides will be available
when you go back to your homes.
Click on the CDN site.
Run some trace routes.
It will be the same IP.
You'll be able to see that it's
always a few milliseconds away
from you.
With that, I'd like
to summarize and say
that we focused on ease of
use, security, and performance.
I'm not going to
repeat the bullets.
Those are sort of the
key aspects of the CDN
that we want to share
with our customers.
And I have an obligation
to also tell you
that there is a lot of beautiful
networking talks up next.
I encourage you to attend
as many of them as you can
and learn about
the great network
that Google Cloud has to offer.
And since everybody likes
swag, if you want a beautiful
poster-- you know, nice, glossy
to put on your wall of, you
know, how great the
Google network is--
g.co/poster, put
your information,
and we'll be happy
to give you one.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]